bon alors revenons à vous on apprend en
lisant tristes tropiques que votre
carrière s'est joué je vous cite un
dimanche de l'automne 1934 à 9 heures du
matin sur un coup de téléphone à moi
c'est précis mais c'est tout à fait vrai
j'avais vu était très hésitant sur le
choix d'une carrière
en fait j'avais commencé à songer
prépare une normale j'y ai renoncé parce
que je savais pas assez bien le grec
mon professeur de cagnes m'a dit vous
n'êtes pas fait pour la philosophie vous
a créé pour le droit y sentez qu'il y
avait quelque chose dans sa vie s'était
pas si faux j'ai donc commencé des
études de droit
seulement comme c'était très facile à
l'époque savez on apprenait un aide
mémoire
quinze jours avant l'examen et on
n'allait pas au cours alors j'ai fait en
même temps une licence de philosophie et
puis je me suis aperçu que c'était
plutôt vers la philosophie que j'allais
bon je suis devenu professeur de
philosophie dans un lycée de province à
mont-de-marsan
oui à mont de marsan c'est à dire j'ai
commencé à mont-de-marsan le 1er octobre
1932 et j'ai pris ma retraite le 1er
octobre 1982 c'est à dire jour pour jour
cinquante ans après vous voyez qu'il a
précisé le calendrier ça compte dans mon
existence et le sentiment enfin que
j'allais passer ma vie y répéter un
cours non c'était pas possible surtout
quand même temps j'avais un très grand
gouttes laventure sous des formes très
modeste mais enfin dès l'enfance j'ai
essayé de transformer disons le paysage
français rural ou urbain en terrain
d'aventuré
comment ou comment avec mes camarades
quand nous étions ou lycée mont le jeudi
ou le dimanche le jeudi c'est jour de
congé à l'évent on se disait on va
partir de tels endroits de paris puis on
va marcher tout droit en direction de la
banlieue on ira exactement où si loin
mais sans jamais à fléchir notre
direction à droite ou à gauche que nos
jambes pourront nous porter alors ça
nous sommes
dans des aventures extraordinaires
faisait du camping alors oui nous avons
fait également du camping je me rappelle
une expérience de camping nous n'avions
pas assez d'argent pour nous acheter une
tente c'était un article de luxe à
l'époque nous avions loué une bâche que
nous transportions comme un cadavre sur
un bon cas puis nous sommes partis des
faubourgs de rouen nous allons marcher
toute la journée nous avons dormi dans
les logiciels les plus inconfortables
lendemain matin nous sommes aperçus que
nous étions à 4 kilomètres de rouen
parce que nous avions suivi une boucle
de la seine qui nous avait ramené à
neutre notre point de départ et ça a été
la fin des expériences donc mais enfin
le camping s'était pas tellement répandu
à cette épreuve
donc il s'agissait pour moi de tâches et
d'associer une profession qui a été
celle de professeur de philosophie et
puis le goût de l'aventuré dont à ce
moment là la technologie l'exemple le
soustelle le montrer sous son aile est
un petit peu mon cadet mais lui n'a
jamais eu de doutes sur sa vocation et
on savait déjà à l'époque qui avait un
agrégé de philo vie qui était parti pour
le mexique qui punit de partir bon je me
suis dit pourquoi pas élancé ce coup de
téléphone qui vous alors j'ai fait
savoir mme et m que j'aimerais un poste
à l'étranger c'était pas très recherché
vous savez les peuples et les
universitaires n'est même pas tellement
voyagé et un bon matin bouclier qui
était directeur de l'école normale parce
qu'elles font aimer dieu ce que voulu
partir pour le brésil
et vous êtes parti pour le brésil
comptait une chose étonnante c'est
qu'ils avaient des jeunes et quelques
temps après avec l'ambassadeur du brésil
enfance il vous a dit on mais toute
façon les indiens y en a plus au brésil
ah oui quand même
mais ça on n'aimait pas tellement dans
les milieux ça a changé depuis mais dans
la haute bourgeoisie où l'aristocratie
brésilienne on m ait pas tellement se
rappeler qu' il y avait des indiens et
surtout pour les avaient massacré